what is goodie
hot breath the verse welcome to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
our guest today is a comedian who has
really found his voice in this game and
be able to create a successful career
based off his specific skill sets and
that's something every comedian can
learn from is
instead of us trying to do everything
it's like what is naturally
what are we naturally good at what are
we naturally having fun doing and making
our own
careers as opposed to trying to imitate
what else is out there
so i'm so thrilled to have this comedian
on the show today we are all about
helping cultivate the next generation of
great comics and this guy is definitely
part
of the current generation of great
comics and is only going to grow from
here so we're excited to get him at this
point in his career
so please welcome to the show mr chris
turner ladies and gentlemen make it up
for chris turner everyone
yeah we love you chris oh thanks
audience hey
pleasure to be here joel turn up thanks
for being here chris
thank you um nice to to be
with you i you didn't tell me we were
going to be helping the next generation
of comics i
definitely do not want to aid anyone
coming up and
knocking the current generation off
their throne um
so everything i say will be a lie no i
should clarify
when i i listened back to myself on some
podcast recently and i was like
oh this guy thinks he knows everything i
want to say up top i'm going to i want
to talk in this podcast as if i know
things and this if what i say is
accurate and true uh please
bear in mind that i i know very little
and i am
purely a humble little british boy who
thinks he knows things but probably
doesn't so yeah just
that's my disclaimer up top and no
worries like that's
that we've done over 300 of these
interviews and i mean the consensus is
at the end of the day you have to find
what works for you
as a comedian and you just have to be
willing to put in the work
i think that's a lot of the times with
so much comedy content out there is
we can get lost in just learning
learning learning instead of applying
and really experimenting and figuring
out
what works for ourselves so that's
really
as a comedian who's been in this game 11
years myself
that i i found that i wasted a lot of
time
just delaying actually application as
opposed to just
executing and learning by doing so i'm
hoping this show
is a good reminder for comics that yes
learn from these great comedians
but you have to be willing to put in
that work
i mean i think that's true of anything
isn't it although you can't put in work
at the moment because there's no
nowhere to do shows and if there is it's
still
morally dubious to go and spread viruses
around
but you're you're one of the almost a
few i mean you're one of the rare
comedians who has been able to like
thrive in a sense from seemingly you
know i was booked solid last year
and then all sudden in march it
evaporates so i just started focusing on
the podcast and really building the
community
around it and doing some virtual shows
but how
when that moment hit for you i guess in
march
like what what was that like for you and
what was your mindset around that and to
make the most of this opportunity
instead of like complaining
um i don't think i set out with a
specific mindset for it so for people
who may not know
uh i i i've been doing
i mean why would people know this i've
been doing a lot of virtual shows but
specifically in the corporate sector
um rather than publicly um
and i've been very fortunate with that
and it's kind of a
web of things so my my college agent
did a really quick pivot and as soon as
lockdown happened
and colleges couldn't have live shows
she just reached out to all of her acts
and said hey
you guys need to get a virtual product
asap because these colleges now need to
replace acts and there's so many acts
that aren't
able to quickly adapt and so i
i very quickly started doing virtual
college gigs i
started doing you know i i already
am fortunate to do a lot of corporate
work mainly in the uk
um and so virtual i could just do that
from you know from la where i was at the
time i
left after a few months the pandemic
when it became clear that la was
really gonna struggle and i just wanted
to kind of keep myself and my
my wife safe and
yeah i i just emailed out anyone who'd
booked me and said hey
you're going to have all these zoom
meetings they're going to be boring why
not book me
and then i just kind of try to figure
out pricing structures and
figure out what else i could do and get
recommendations and then put out some
you know
some like testimonials you do a gig you
get some good feedback you get a clip
you send that to other people they then
want to book you
and it just kind of snowballed from
there because it's it's really hard like
it's really hard to do virtual comedy um
it's nothing it's
it's a different beast to being on stage
and again this is me
giving advice that i don't know if it's
accurate but i i feel that
several comedians i know who are very
good i think
early on tried to replicate their stage
act in a virtual environment and i don't
think that's
how you thrive i think you have to
create a new product for it um
to call comedy a product you have to
approach it from a different way um
it doesn't just translate so i was also
lucky to
have done live streaming for a year
before the pandemic hit so i had all the
equipment i needed
like at the start of the pandemic i you
know people were saying oh i can't get a
green screen it's sold out oh i can't
get a microphone it's sold out
everywhere
i mean i couldn't get a pull-up bar they
were sold out everywhere that was my
my excuse for having tiny arms but i
i just had all this equipment so very
quickly i could do all these shows and
to a high quality and because
of what i do which is heavily based in
improv
i i was able to bring the shows a level
of interactivity which engages people
because when you're at your screen all
day at your job and then your boss says
hey we're having a zoom get together
tonight
it's so easy to just sit there and just
turn your camera off and do something
else on your phone
but because i was soliciting suggestions
from the audience i was interacting with
them i was spotlighting them getting
them on screen and doing bits about them
that meant that i i was engaging the
audience in a way that i think
people took a while to cotton onto i
think now you know i've seen
so many comedians with incredible
virtual performances
um and i'm just watching them like oh
wow they really went all in on this like
they're doing so much cool stuff
but for those first few months um i mean
so like morgan j
is doing awesome stuff um morgan does
lots of musical comedy and his we were
chat
we did a show together and we chatted
about it because it was very
his set just was unstructured in a very
good way
he didn't have bits he was doing he'd
just spotlight some people and then
start talking about them with all these
effects on his voice and all these
different cameras he'd switched to and
it was really chaotic and fun and it
felt
like something you couldn't do live but
something you could do virtually
so it felt bespoke and created just for
them um
whereas otherwise well why don't we just
watch a clip of someone on stage doing a
set
um darren walsh is a comedian in the uk
who i did a show with and he
runs everything through um q lab so he's
got all these
sound cues and video cues that he just
presses a little button on his stream
deck and
it takes over his camera it's not like
share screen it just takes over the
footage you're seeing and
things happen with his face on the
screen and it's just super rapid fire
quick gags and he's a one-liner comedian
he's very very good at writing puns
and so it's just this barrage of like
audio-visual
comedy which was what he did live but
he's really pivoted it to a
virtual audience and seeing those people
i'm like oh wow they've
done so much more work in it than me but
i think just i benefited from
being very lucky having the right things
at the right time and
an act that already lent itself to
interaction and the corporate
sector because the thing is virtual
comedy gigs
aren't as good as live comedy gigs but
corporates whether virtual or live are
always horrible
so so it's it's like
it's not like no one's people aren't
going people say that comedy gig wasn't
as good as a live one
but with corporate things people like oh
that didn't suck
and that's all you want from a corporate
um again when i started out doing
corporates in the uk
it's not like i killed every corporate
but i didn't
bomb most of them and that's what you
need to do as a corporate comic is
to not suck because a lot of the time
you'd do a gig and you'd be like that
didn't go very well
and afterwards they'd tell you oh wow
you did so much better than
the act last year and you're like oh
yeah i guess i didn't get booed off
stage so
yeah level that's not to demean my
comedy or good corporate acts you know
i think i do very very very good
corporate shows um
but i think that's why corporates have
become
not too much more difficult in the
virtual sphere whereas live comedy shows
versus virtual company shows virtual
company shows are much harder
yeah that's interesting from the
business side of that how your agent was
saying
you need a virtual product it's almost
like you you need
it's a bespoke approach to a live show
because i'm
i'm now looking i'm not quite sure when
the world's opening back up i'm like i
i want to be more intentional about
trying to book more virtual shows
you know and i'll be like because i do
see the benefit in the ones i have done
but i would like to gain more momentum
and start to build somewhat of a more
business approach to it so like what
kind of tips do you have for that
um i mean i've not been booking virtual
shows i you know i've performed on
virtual shows that have been
booked by so what i'm talking about most
of my shows that are corporates i book
myself and it's
me doing you know what however long 20
minutes 30 minutes an hour for a virtual
audience a corporate client but there
are promoters who are
putting together packages for corporate
clients where it's
five acts performing um and you know
some of those people i've worked with
have
been doing really well like they've
really packaged their
their sales techniques and they're
selling these shows to big companies and
like with all respect to them they're i
think actually paying comedians quite a
good
chunk of what they're getting for the
show like it seems fair
which is really nice and very um
commendable because it would be so easy
for
you know someone to book a show take
most of the money and then split you
know 10
of it between the comedians because
we're comedians we want to do gigs right
um
but these these seem like people putting
on shows to
actually help comedians survive through
this by making an income
um i don't have much
advice on how to kind of put that
together i think it's trial and error to
figure out what makes a good virtual
show if you're having a mixed lineup
but a friend of mine who runs a club in
the uk which i really really
love when i can perform there they've
started doing a casual show on fridays
at 9 00 p.m in the evening
uk time called the drop in and it's just
free and anyone can the link's always
the same
you can go to that link and it's going
to be an hour of
some comedians will swing by and at the
front of house so what the audience is
seeing is the host is always there and
then comedians pop into a set and
disappear
but the the breakout room is the benefit
the beneficial part of it for comedians
because
they're just treating it like a green
room so comedians would just pop into
this green room and
i was there you know for like the second
or third one they did and there was like
20 different comedians coming in over
the course of the hour
people would just you know come they're
not even on the show they'd just drop in
hang out
chat and it felt like it felt like a
real show was really really nice and
obviously
it's been a year of us being on zoom so
that people have kind of understood that
push and pull there wasn't as much
talking over each other as you might
have had six months ago
you know someone would start a story and
then leave some space some other stories
would come in
someone would pop in for five minutes
you know just hang out and disappear
um and that was really nice i it's kind
of the closest i've got to being in a
green room
the you know for a year um
and i think that is you know i've done
shows where we had like no one
watching but the the show was just hey
we're gonna get four acts together
you're each going to do a little set but
you know maybe don't
treat it like oh you're type five just
do five
like talk about stuff and then we'll
have a half hour discussion
like a round table and that was really
fun like there was no audience but
it was just chatting with comedians
about stuff sharing stories again
because i think that's what we missed
right i mean performing is great but
it's
the company backstage and right like
hearing about
people's lives and you know because they
they're your friends and that's that's
what we've missed so
yeah i think that having that aspect in
any virtual shows is
good otherwise it just feels like you're
logging on to
entertain for five minutes then
disappearing yeah that's a lot of what
i've been doing or i've been doing
birthday parties and whatnot but even
it's born booked as like a stand-up
show but it's thinking yeah i think
comics can start to think of yeah what
is
what other unique talents do i have can
i do magic can i play the harmonica just
how what can i use effects you know what
are ways i can spice up the format a
little bit
that's good to know yeah and thinking of
like a live performance because this is
something that
you're so great at and i've heard you
mention that when you do your rapping
that you get into like a flow state and
when you're on stage it's about being in
the moment and that's something comics
struggle with so much is being in the
moment
not panicking how what kind of tips do
you have for comics to like just
relax on stage and be more in the moment
so this is with the the caveat that i
when i'm doing stand-up it's very rare
that i get
in the zone of stand-up because to get
into a flow state you have to have
you know the the requirements are
ability
and challenge have to match and you're
you have to be good enough and the
challenge has to be hard enough now
stand-up comedy is a challenge making an
audience laugh
is the challenge that we have and our
ability
hopefully meets that right but there's a
certain point where
and it's why flow state usually comes
from riffs it comes from when you're
improvising and i think that's the
closest i've
felt in my stand up is when i'm
so this is why when you're reciting
material
or in acting out material to make it
seem improvised
it's hard to be in the flow state
because you're remembering the material
you're thinking of what comes next
this is why with improv when you're
riffing say you
something happens in the front row you
comment on it and then that
spirals and snowballs into a real nice
little kind of extended riff
that's when i can feel if it's happened
you know that frequently
that's when i feel more in the zone um
but
with freestyle because that is entirely
improvised within a structure
you set the challenge which is to
freestyle rap about these things and
make it entertaining and interesting and
informative
and i would hope that my ability is you
know
up to doing that i'm not saying i get
into flow every time i freestyle but the
vast majority of times it happens
and i know it's happened because if i
get off stage and can't remember what i
rapped about
then i was in flow because it was you
know unconscious
that makes it sound like i black out
when i'm rapping which maybe is not the
right word for it but
part of it
so i
my advice for it is i think it's hard to
get into flow with written material
i'm sure people do it but you know like
because
having everyone like having huge laughs
at the end of each tag is not being in
flow which means you've got the room
rolling right
but it's it's really hard because once
you notice you're in it's like breathing
once you think about breathing you have
to actively do it rather than doing it
subconsciously and that's what flow
should be
it's as soon as you notice it you'll
come out of flow and i've had that
before where i've like been riffing and
then
i've been like in my head going oh i'm
killing this and then suddenly you just
feel the laughs change they're like
oh he's aware of what's happening now um
so it's hard to give concrete tips for
it i think
other than the more you practice riffing
the more you at these low pressure gigs
say
i'm not gonna you know i'm gonna have
i don't even think you should be like
i'm gonna come on with because this is
how i would practice it
i'd come on stage and i'd say i'm not
gonna use an opener
i'm gonna keep my opener in my pocket
and i'm gonna try and just make them
laugh without an opener i'm gonna try
and
get a laugh from nowhere and your safety
net is your opener right you know you've
got a joke that's gonna get them
even if you've had 30 seconds where
they're a bit like
unsure of who you are your first joke
should be strong enough that
say you just kind of flail around 30
seconds you do that first joke
boom you've got them but what i would do
as a practice is go on stage with no
jokes and just be like
just say hello and then comment on what
happens after that
now that's not going to work every time
because the room might not be in the
mood for it and you might not be in the
zone for it
but that's a good way to practice and in
the same way that that's how you
write on stage you know you do your
routine
and you leave spaces after your punch
lines
and you create an improvised tag for it
i'm not saying again it's the thing i do
that frequently or it's the thing that
has worked out for me that often
but the times it does it's pretty fun to
walk on say you've got your routine
about dinosaurs and you just do your bit
and you've done your big punch line and
you know you're going to go on to the
next bit before moving to the next bit
just in that space is there something
else you can say
can you comment on a reaction to the
joke can you push the punchline further
like there are people who you know say
you should just
keep pushing until everyone stops
laughing and then start the new joke
um and that's kind of a flow state
because then you write
in a way you wouldn't write if you were
sitting down actively trying to write
i really think i've given very few tips
here but uh that is my aim i don't want
anyone to learn my secrets
you're doing great buddy no worries no
worries at all this is all super helpful
i love interviewing comedians especially
like ones that are
funny and good at comedy and then you
ask them about it and they're like i
don't know if any of this is making
sense i don't even know what i'm doing i
got lucky like there's always all this
backtracking a lot of the times
you're doing great this is helpful i've
had times at the edinburgh festival
after a show someone will come up to me
and they'll you know you'll be having a
drink with some other comedians
uh after the shows you're all kind of in
the bar and someone come up with me hey
i saw your show it's
so great um and the thing that my fans
often say because they're all
and this is the said very lovely they're
all massive nerds they'll
say things like you're my fourth
favorite comedian
and i remember it happening once and
this comedian goes because
wow that's the rudest thing i've ever
heard uh after the guy had gone and i
was like why is that rude he's like that
guy just dissed you
i said no that guy paid a huge
compliment because
if i'm your fourth favorite comedian oh
my god you need to watch more comedy
there's so many better comedians than me
two that means that he's put thought
into it he's been like okay so my
favorite comedians are listing these
three
and then chris turner he's number four
and the number five is the person i'm
like what an honor someone who's thought
about it that much really loves comedy
so to be someone's fourth favorite you
know i'm not i'm not my favorite
comedian i'm not my favorite fourth
fourth favorite comedian i'm you know i
i mean that's you know aside from the
fact that i hate watching myself perform
i'm maybe in my top 25
maybe so who's your you know
what's your top five top five uh not
particularly i'm sure it's
it changes you know i mean whenever
people say in america when people say
who's your favorite comedian and this is
you know obviously over a year ago when
i would be in an uber if you would go
oh you know you go to a comedy club who
would you like i'd go james a caster and
they're like i don't know who that is
he's from the uk he's got four netflix
specials if you haven't seen them
you should definitely watch them they're
the best comedy specials that i've seen
in the last few years
um but then people go oh okay um
and then beyond that it's nice to just
have your favorite comedians
be people you know and work with like
ivan decker is an amazing comedian
i he is a friend but that doesn't change
the fact that whenever i watch him i'm
like ah
you're really good at comedy um
i i did if i did a virtual show which
someone reached out they were like hey
he did this show and i was like
and they went ivan's on i was like oh
yeah i'll do that show great cool that
gives me an excuse to watch ivan
and that was fun that's what i'll do
now it's like chris did the podcast so
well he he
he made a joke he said on the show the
only reason we've got this guy on is
because ivan was on and
he said he wants to see ivan what he
doesn't know is the only reason ivan's
on the show is because i told ivan that
chris would be on it
which is not that is not the case but um
i did like that a lot that's great
that's super savvy
so let's let's get to some um fan
questions here as well because
fan questions have fans come on
you have fans there's several people in
here
just who had questions about like
one-liners and things like that but i
think
um one we could really jump into
first is maybe like the evolution of
your style so bob jorgensen
asked about you used to be very dry
deadpan style
that changed over time was this
deliberate and if so
why yeah um so again to take people who
aren't bob
through my kind of narrative i
started doing comedy at university so i
was at oxford university studying
archaeology and anthropology
training to be i was intending to become
a lawyer um
which seems weird but in the uk you do a
separate degree then you do a law
conversion degree
and i
i would just i started doing improv with
the oxford imps improv group in oxford
and i thought that was really fun
and i thought i should give stand up a
go and i was just writing
these kind of quick little jokes and
that's partially because you know the
comedians that i liked
back then were like jimmy carr and
doesn't say i don't
still like these people but you know
you'd watch steven wright and jimmy carr
and anthony jeselnik and
i really liked those kind of just quick
jokes and it felt
you know it's it's hard to perform i
never had i always feel starting out you
have either material or delivery
i mean you might have neither but you
have you're better at one than the other
and i was definitely better at material
than delivery
and i couldn't really sell my jokes very
well so i was like okay i'll just be
deadpan
and that way i can just tell these jokes
and it worked quite well i
the jokes i was coming up with were
smart because when you're focusing on
academic work your brain is constantly
thinking of smart things and
your your brain turns out jokes based on
you know
what you've been thinking about so
therefore i was just thinking about all
these kind of like intellectual things
that come with these
like clever one-liners write them down
go on stage and you know also
you know deadpan you can do a 10-minute
set with only five minutes worth of
jokes because you just put loads of
pauses in so that's good
um you don't have to write more good
jokes you just do
these you know half the number you
normally need
and after about two years two and a half
years of doing deadpan
i because it went down well because
people there weren't many comedians
doing it
it was unusual to see someone as young
as me because i was 19 doing it
and and my jokes were like quite good i
think there were good jokes i still do
lots of them in my shows because i like
them as jokes just not deadpan
and when i started doing opening spots
which in the uk it's kind of different
to america
the most experienced act will be the mc
or the headliner
then the open will be the second most
experienced then the the newer act will
be in the middle spot the middle spot's
going to be five to ten minutes and
maybe there'll be a couple of middle
spots on the show that's you trying out
your open spot
whereas obviously lots of american clubs
the mc might be newer or they put the
newer person up front
in the uk that's not how it works so i
do my middle spots doing five ten
minutes of deadpan it would go well
and this is before i ever started
rapping on stage uh i'd rap since i was
12 but never on stage
i i was given open spots people say okay
we want to try you out for you know 15
20 minutes opening the show
and it was really hard it was so hard to
open a show deadpan it's it's hard to do
deadpan for more than i think 15 minutes
because the audience get kind of it's
monotone they get lulled
by it so i asked a comedian
called gary delaney who's amazing
amazing one-liner comedian
and and you know doing very well now in
the uk um
he'd been on the circuit for quite a
while already and i asked him
what did you do to kind of get over this
opening hump and he said that he used to
be deadpan
and it took him i think he said three
years to figure out
how to open a show and he just realized
you had to change your style you had to
um loosen up and he started laughing at
his own jokes and becoming more kind of
casual and engaging with the audience
rather than creating this
weird plexiglas barrier so
i just switched i just became more
gregarious i became more chatty
still doing the same jokes but maybe
throwing in a story or two
um and that was great because that
helped me
open better because it wasn't like your
first act
hello comedy it was more like oh hi
comedy time
and the audience liked that so because
you know these are clubs weekend clubs
in the uk where it's
bachelor parties bachelorette parties if
you come on and you're weird they'll
laugh for a few minutes but then they
get weirded out whereas if you come on
and engage normally like you you don't
put a weird act up top
you put it in the middle or they're good
enough for their weirdness that they're
closing it would be unusual to have them
open so
you know i'm sure that i could have
sustained the deadpan if i wanted to
and figured out how to make an audience
like it but maybe it would have taken me
three
or more years um but also
deadpan is not how i am offstage that
was a kind of persona i put on to deal
with the fact that i was a new comedian
and i was you know
not scared of the stage but not
comfortable on it yet
and the more comedy you do i think the
more you
revert to yourself off stage on stage
and then the the rap came about because
i
i used to rap in my kids comedy shows i
used to put on
and a critic saw it and was like wow
that's really impressive you should do
that in your adult shows and i thought
huh do you think they'd like it and
they're like yeah so i started doing it
at the end of my sets
i would close with the freestyle which
was fun because it would be a
kind of a hard change from hey here's
some jokes boom now rap
and that meant that i i'd be opening a
show and
you do a wrap and it really kind of
elevates the energy so you become quite
a good opener but then
it would be hard for the act in the
middle to follow it
so i then had clubs just
i think you know my first headline spot
properly was because i was at a club and
they said
you know they'd always had me open and
then the headliner didn't show up
and said i'm not going to be there and i
was the most experienced out of
some very inexperienced acts on the bill
they said chris can you close
and i i was like okay i don't really
think i have like a strong
30 minutes but i can do a wrap up top do
20 minutes of jokes and then a close of
the wrap
and that worked you know reasonably well
and they said oh that it was really cool
to have the rap to finish the show we'll
just keep putting you on at the end
next time just you know you know give it
six months to maybe like
yeah beef up some of the jokes um
and then more and more clubs would start
putting me on at the end because you put
it on in the middle or the start and
i definitely i
kind of doubt because it felt very
gimmicky and i still contend it is right
it's
but when i was a newer comic i thought
playing guitar on stage oh a six string
applause machine that's disgraceful
um and then i'm like oh i'm wrapping
that's even worse
but if you i asked my agent i said
should i i'd done a show where i was in
the middle doing 20 minutes i ended with
a rap
and then the headliner hadn't seen me
and they were doing some kind of musical
comedy and they did a written wrap and
it just didn't go down very well
because the audience you could see the
order just going yeah but that guy in
the middle did a rap and he made it up
and so i the guy came off stage and was
a little bit snarky
saying oh they hated that and someone
said oh well it's because chris did a
wrap and he's like what you did a rap
like
oh i do raps and i was like oh i i
didn't know and also
you know it's kind of different and i
said to my agent
should i not rap if i'm not closing and
he went no
[ __ ] everyone else you should do this
they should be better
um which is you know fun i mean
now i'm more comfortable with it because
i'm like oh no i'm i'm quite good at
what i do like my freestyling is
impressive not just because it's from a
white british guy it's impressive
for freestyling and one of the great
things about being in la and being in
new york was
you do do the do some freestyling for a
crowd
and people would come at you afterwards
and be like hey
you know i grew up freestyling and like
you're good
or you know hey i know this person and
they're an amazing freestyler and
like so it was cool to see you do that
and that's nice
um but i think that's how it that's how
the evolution happened
um and it's you know for some people
they're like oh i
i liked it more when you do deadpan and
i totally understand that
um you know in the same way like one of
my favorite bands when i was growing up
was clutch
and then as they got more famous they
started becoming their genres kind of
changed and i'm like okay i listened to
their records
up until about you know 2007 and then
after that i'm less interested in their
music
that's fine i don't write to them and
complain no that's not to say people
write to me and complain
but um yeah it kind of felt partly
natural
partly guided by needing to be
commercially
um viable in terms of getting bookings
and also not being brave enough to
persist
in a kind of uncommercial thing like
there's so many comedians i watch who
are great
and i'm like wow i can't believe you're
doing that crazy stuff and you're also
on tv or getting these big bookings
but you know it was never like i
was like oh i want to be a deadpan
comedian but i can't do it i was just
like oh
cool i can finally be me on stage um
which is nice be you on stage yeah
that's all of our goals
what is what is like your worst bomb in
trying to
develop the the the confidence to be
yourself on stage is there a bomb that
you'll just never forget
um i mean there was one that was kind of
a semi bomb
in that it was like one of my first
christmas gigs which are famously awful
um just full of drunk people a club
called junglers
which is just again like full of drunk
people and i was
on in the middle of the the show so even
though i was
you know i was experienced enough to be
given a weekend gig at christmas
but still the least experienced on the
lineup and you know the opening act
when they go on there's this table of
about 30
uh squaddies so people who are in the
military
and every joke he does they tag his
punchline with
way so you do a joke and they'd react
like it was a really bad pun
regardless of whether it was a pun or
not and then
he comes off and he's like oh they were
pieces of [ __ ]
they need to throw them out and the
venue manager says well they're buying a
lot of alcohol so the club won't let us
throw them out because they're spending
a lot of money
just they'll they'll calm down so the mc
brings me on for the middle and i do my
first joke
and they just boo and my first joke is
not controversial right
i was like oh wow if i upset them i do
my second joke
and they boo and i realized oh
everything i do they're gonna boo they
did away for the first guy they're gonna
boo
me and the whole audience just start
kind of quieting down apart from this
table of people booing
and so i this is the time i was doing 20
minutes
i i did jokes and then i ended with a
wrap but
i just thought okay fine um i'll do a
rap so i just
i was like hey can you drop that beat
and then i just rapped about these guys
and just kind of like
not rap battle because they're not
responding but just rapped about them
and at the end of it they like cheer
they're like
oh and then i went right now we can get
back to some proper comedy
and they go boom and i was like
seriously are you guys
gonna boo unless i rap and they're like
boo
so i was like i have 12 minutes left
i guess i just have to do three more
wraps or something
but because at the time i'd only i was
used to only doing one wrap per set
i'd given the dj a cd with one track on
so i had to use the same beat
four times in that set just rapping each
time because otherwise they would boot
and afterwards one of them comes up to
me he's like fair play mate that was you
dealt with us well i mean
you know we had planned to boo whoever
was on stage
um but then we saw it was you and we
thought oh my god we're going to boo
this guy because i mean i'm 21
22 whatever it was of course they're
going to boo me
so that that was you know close
um the one of the biggest bombs was my
one of my first corporate gigs which was
at a venue which is
like famously terrible really hard to
perform it's like an
1100 seat room where there used to be an
ice rink
um and i
i i was i thought i was the comedian but
i wasn't i was just kind of the
the fluffer because there was a comedian
a good comedian later on in the show and
they actually did quite well
um but they're like we always have a
problem with this gig they
we can never get the attention for the
boss to come on and speak
so we want you to go up there get all
their eyes on the stage just do
10 minutes and then we'll bring the boss
on and i
at the time was like yeah cool i can do
that you know whereas now i'd just be
like why don't you just dim the lights
have a loud bit of music and then put
the lights on the stage right then
that'll give them attention everyone's
eating it's lunch time it's an
advertising awards and to make it worse
this gig is for one of the biggest
corporate booking agencies in the uk
and this is the first time they've tried
me they're like oh we you know we've
heard good things about you
and they throw me in on this gig and i
later realized this is the gig they give
to people to try and blood them
essentially like if you do this gig you
could do any gig
and you know the end of the story is i
did not do this gig and they didn't book
me for two years
you know now you know they then i think
then saw me at another gig
and they were like wow you're really
good hey wait we put you before we
didn't re-book you like
did it go badly i was like oh it went
really badly so now i get a lot of work
from which is great but
i mean also i wasn't ready um for this
type of gig i'd been doing core
breakings but nothing of this scale
um and so they said okay we're gonna
bring you on because it's a christmas
show we're gonna have
and this is christmas corporate so it's
even worse than a normal christmas show
um we've got a will ferrell look alike i
hadn't seen elf so i thought why have
you got a will ferrell look alike what's
he got to do with christmas
and he's going to lead onto stage a live
reindeer
and then they're going to bring you on
so i'm there and then they go oh um we
just found out that will ferrell
can't do the buddy the elf voice so
like he's just gonna wave
bring the ranger on and then you're
gonna come on and again i was still so
inexperienced
i thought okay so
the the lights don't go down it's still
a brightly lit room and there's 1100
people
on different levels and balconies and
this voiceover goes please welcome chris
turner
no one applauds and then there's elf
walks on stage
slowly leading a reindeer stands on
stage waving at people
then walks off with the reindeer and
then i have to get on stage but it's
taken
maybe 90 seconds from the announcement
to me getting on stage
since i walk on stage i was like oh hey
everyone good to see you
nothing and like again i was so nervous
i didn't comment
on what had just happened right all it
would have taken for me
was to go well that was weird right like
that's all you need to do you need to
comment on a weird thing that happens so
when i
like when i play the comedy seller i i'm
often put on at the end because the rap
is so high energy that like it closes
the night out but that means you'll be
on after incredible comedians so like
the first time i was on after michelle
wolf
and she had like torn the room to pieces
everyone's like well that has to be the
final act because no one can follow that
the mc's like oh we got one more app for
you please welcome chris turner
and obviously everyone had been assuming
that if there's an act after michelle
they must be really famous
and i walk on and everyone's just
looking at me very puzzled
and i just get to the microphone i'm
like i have to comment on this and i
just said i know i also wish i was a
famous comedian
and it got a nice laugh and that's it
and like that's now you know
the opener to use whenever you follow a
famous comedian for me
none of your can have that that's
and so i get on stage don't comment on
it and just no one pays attention at
this gig
and so i'm there for about a minute
doing jokes and no one's laughing or
even listening
i was like okay right i'm gonna do a
wrap for you guys i need your input
nothing not even like a heckle no one
even going get off
it was just no one paid attention to the
fact i was there they spoke
louder so like the band low when they
started out playing
they used to play really quietly so that
bars would quiet down to hear what they
were playing
and that's a good tactic um so all i did
was i just sat on the edge of the stage
kind of swinging my legs and there were
two tables near the stage and i
went hey guys excuse me um do you mind
if i
do you mind if i rap for you and they
were like what and i was like yeah i'm a
rapper
oh we wonder what you were doing and so
i just asked them some suggestions just
rap for these two tables
they enjoyed it so i was like oh i've
snatched defeat from the jaws of victory
by entertaining 20 people out of 1100
um and later that day
i'm still at the event uh because again
it wasn't like a bomb where you want to
leave
it just didn't go well but no one knew i
was on and i bump into this guy and he
went
you're chris turner yeah he goes oh
you're really funny
are you on today i said i was on he was
like
wait really i was like oh that's how
little attention anyone's playing
um and i i tell that story to you know
when you're in agreement told that story
someone and so i went oh i did that gig
that's the advertising association
awards i went yeah and they went
oh yeah um i got some advice for that
one uh
i just walked on and um i called them
all the c
word and so this she was a female comic
and she had just walked on and just just
gone
hear a bunch of c words and they'd all
gone sorry what i was like i had their
attention
wow that's how she had done it was yeah
yeah
i was like oh that's good although at
the time you know i'd be told you'd
never swear at corporate i mean she was
a you know television level comedian so
i think she got away with it
but yeah that's you know and since then
there have been there was a big thing a
couple of years ago where a comedian was
bread rolled off the stage at not that
gig but in that venue
an audience just starts around bread
rolls with them to get them on stage i
mean that's because
they were like they're a very good uh
liberal comedian and the audience was
quite old and right-wing and i think he
started teasing them and then they just
started throwing bread rolls in
[Laughter]
the things we do for comedy in the
in the last few minutes here let let's
do a few rapid fire
from a few comics here um and we can
just give them like
quick answers here um i'm aware i give
bloated responses so i do apologize
they're all valuable though
chris no worries my friend there's only
been one guest
uh brandon t jackson he just kept
talking around the questions
i would like to ask about what it's like
to work with ben stiller and he would
bring up like
the conspiracy of egypt i don't he kept
just like
going in circles but everyone else like
everyone else has been great so no
worries your answers are all super good
it's what i mean thank you thank you for
not shaming my answers
so um lee hudson actually um a a uk
comedian who's a member of the hot
breath verse here
he says what is one thing you think the
uk comedy industry could learn from the
us
and vice versa
the main difference between the two
scenes
i believe is in the audiences american
audiences sit there
going wow i can't wait for this show to
start
i'm really excited to have a fun time
british audiences sit there thinking
who are these people that think they're
funny let's see if they can entertain me
and i think if there is a way for
british audiences
to be influenced to be more like
american audiences in that sense and i
don't mean like
to give standing ovations the moment you
walk on i know kevin hart filmed a
special in the uk
and my friend who was there said it was
weird because this guy came out was like
hey when kevin walks on everyone stand
up and cheer and the audience are just
like why
we'll do that at the end if he's done
the show but um but
i i really think gigs are easier in
america because
the audience go oh i'm here for a good
time i can't wait whereas british
audiences they're like
go on there let's see if this is funny
and i don't know if there's a fix to
that
on the flip side i really do
dislike the american practice of you've
seen this person on
and then they list their credits in the
uk we don't do that and i know i've been
in the room where an emcee was given by
an american act a list of credits
uh and they just went on they were like
um you haven't seen him on any of these
shows because they're all on american
shows and why would you watch those
please welcome
um like my favorite introduction is just
you know uh good friend very funny
person please welcome chris turner
like that's the thing i also think um
what american comedy could learn from uk
comedy is
i i don't like the thing of the mcs
being
more inexperienced because i think the
mc is crucial to the show
it is um i really like emceeing because
i feel like there's no pressure
because what you're trying to do is just
set the show up and if you're not funny
that's great because everyone else looks
funny by comparison
but really you're just trying to set the
rules you're trying to make sure
everyone feels like they've had a good
evening
you're trying to bring it back around
from maybe an actor who hasn't had a
great set you're trying to
set the energy when an actor stormed it
and you're trying to bring on the next
one and i think it takes a lot of work
and a lot of practice and i'm not saying
that i'm there
but in america because it's the newer
act often it'll be the act just trying
to do their best ten minutes and then
they're like okay the first act and
you're like you haven't even set the
room up for them
so i think that's a thing that that
american
comedy could learn from british comedy
beautiful and
uh mike maher asks how do you remember
one-liners for like a half hour or one
hour set
um i mean i never did longer than 20
minutes with one-liners but
you know i've done six one-hour comedy
shows like at the emerald festival
and it is hard to remember that
it's very hard um i i would just put
them in a narrative
like one line as i put in narrative
blocks it was here are the hip-hop jokes
here are the school jokes here are the
relationship jokes
and you'd make sure they always led on
so you'd say you know
i wish i could show you guys a picture
of my wife so you could see a real world
example of someone banging way above
their average
because she's you know substantially
less attractive than me
and then that naturally feeds into no
i'm joking my wife beautiful long blonde
hair
or a very short back you know and then
people
you know oh when my wife and i got our
apartment you just you know you're
putting them in segments so it
it naturally flows on um
and then also just running through it i
mean i i don't use memorization
techniques people ask that with my rap
they're like oh how you remembering the
words and it's
it's not i just kind of just it's
short-term memory um but
obviously learning a show has to go in
long-term memory but also there's you
know
you can always cheat i've seen one-line
racks just read stuff off a clipboard
and that's part of part of what made
them funny
um milton jones amazing comedian when he
tries out new material
he'll come on stage with you know 30
note cards in his top pocket and he'll
just
you know he'll take them all out at the
start of his set and then he'll read
them off the card and he's not learned
them because he's you know just writing
to try them out
why waste mental energy learning them if
they're not good and he'll read it and
then he'll look at the audience
and if he got a good laugh he'll like
put it to the back of the pack
if he got a really good laugh he'll put
it in his pocket and if he got no laugh
he'll throw it on the floor
um and he gets laughs out of that
technique by virtue of
say something will get no laugh
he'll like look at he might like once in
a sec he might look at the audience
shake his head like they were wrong and
then put it in his pocket like yeah i'm
keeping that joke even though you hated
it
that's that's a fun thing that i've seen
done i mean that's you know his thing
that was very funny watching it yeah
yeah that's jeff are you familiar with
jeff foxworthy
vaguely familiar yeah so he that's
that's part of what he'll do is like
when he's working on material he'll have
three bins on
like three plastic buckets on stage and
one will like
keep her work on it or get rid of it
he'll kind of go through it that way
also
yeah gary delaney the one-liner comedian
i mentioned had a show
i i don't think it was cool it wasn't
called saint and sinner but essentially
that was the
the idea and he had a pocket of like
just coins tokens and he'd just tell his
jokes you know
not reading them off anything and if a
joke got a particularly big laugh
and it was a clean joke he'd throw a
token in like the clean bucket
and then he'd throw a token in the you
know the mean bucket
if it was dirty and they really liked it
and if they really like to throw like
several ones in
and then the end of the show he's like
right time to tally up the numbers and
i end the show with 10 minutes of either
clean material or really disgusting
material
and he'd empty out the buckets and you
see which one had the most he's like oh
you guys seem like a clean audience
i mean i'm pretty sure every single time
it was always the dirty jokes at the end
um but yeah that was a really good
technique he was very
that's very smart i think um he's a
great joke writer anyway yeah we've had
a few people
uh asking to get him on so we'll
definitely have to reach out to him
that's great
gary is gary is incredible um yeah i
love him so much he was so helpful to me
and so
he's so genuinely nice and good and when
a couple years ago he kind of like
popped up popping up on tv
and on like panel shows i think everyone
in the circuit was like
yeah about time like he should have been
on these ages ago
i love seeing that so as we uh as we
land this plane here
um owing and uh chris wright from
scotland says that you and m.c
hammersmith are the best comedic rappers
he's ever seen
just forever that's that's very kind i m
c hammersmith is a friend called will
that's very nice nice so um
our closing closing advice for comedians
like what's your favorite tip you've
gotten or something you always
remind yourself of in this comedy
journey
um i'll give you the one that felt very
personal and then i'll use that time to
try and figure out one i think is
applicable
to others so my maybe 10th gig
was with reginald d hunter who is a
comic from i think georgia but he moved
to the uk
before he even started doing comedy so i
don't think he's known particularly in
the us
um and i i did a you know 10 minute set
on not opening for him but on the same
bill as him when it was just me
and mc and him um at a show in oxford
and i did my set and it went pretty well
as far as my sets at that time were
going and it was kind of weird and this
is when i used to
do weird stuff i walked on stage with
like a shruti box tone generator which
would just make this kind of um
sound i put it by the microphone and
then i just walk to the front of the
stage without a microphone and start
shouting at the audience just doing
one-liners
um that's i used to open with that weird
noise and then i'd walk to the front of
the stage and go a wise man once said
and everyone would just be like what the
[ __ ] is this and then i'd go feet
are just [ __ ] hands
and the audience would laugh and then
i'd go back to the microphone turn off
the box and then just be like good
evening
and it would get like a really good
laugh and it was weird yeah and you know
that's that's definitely a type of
adventurousness that i i had early on
which was really fun and i
you know people like oh why i was so
creative and cool you're like yeah you
didn't see the number of times that it
bombed
[Laughter]
i did he watched my set and after the
show he was rolling a joint in the green
room and i said to him
i was like hey reg i really appreciate
you watching my set um like i really
love reg hunter he's so good
and i've seen his shows before i was
even doing comedy and i said you have
any advice and he went
yeah beef it up and i
said what do you mean he said i ain't
telling you what i mean
and i was like okay and because this is
a comedian i liked and trusted i thought
holy [ __ ] that must be the secret i
gotta beef it up
what does that mean what does that so i
started working out a lot more
and i thought i genuinely thought like
he was like oh you need to look
intimidating
on stage that was not that did not help
um
so i just started eventually i kind of
took it to mean
just hit those punch lines harder you
know you need to
you need to be more authoritative on
stage and i don't even know
it just it made me question my set more
and i think that was the meaning behind
it i mean also he was just high
but maybe maybe by giving me some
cryptic advice it caused me to think
more about what i was doing
rather than just doing it which i think
was useful
um so maybe that is universal advice
aside from that um
yeah i have a poor memory for specific
bits of advice
um i read somewhere i think this was
good was just you know
take a breath off stage
and then hold that breath in don't make
it look like you've got your cheeks all
puffed out but hold that breath in until
you get to the microphone
take the microphone out the stand exhale
and then start your set and it was like
it's something about it's the calming
aspect it
it means that you carry yourself on
stage with better posture
you it forces you to pause it means
you're not stepping you know it we
always feel as comedians like let's
start talking when they're still
applauding and
i actually think you know often i'm not
saying i do this all the time but it's
nice to wait for the applause to die
down
and then start the show it depends on
your energy but
that breath kind of gives you that time
to wait for them to finish applauding
and then you're like
hey thanks so much lovely to be here um
and i've always liked that and i when i
teach you know workshops for like public
speaking with
businesses i i always tell them take a
breath before you talk because
it's it's the first impression right and
if you're talking when they're clapping
they kind of miss that first word and
then they're like oh i should stop
clapping now
you should never stop an audience
clapping there are people who disagree
they're like oh you should you know
tread on the laughter to get keep the
jokes rolling which definitely works at
points we should be varying that
throughout a show anyway
so yeah those beef it up and uh and hold
your breath
beef it up the hashtag beef it up baby
well to uh to uh to close this out would
you mind looking into the camera saying
your name and why people should listen
to hot breath
oh gosh um no pressure yeah well that's
i've not listened to any of the other
episodes so i don't know if they're all
you know
extreme right-wing hate speech um i know
i don't look like i could be
either way yeah yeah i look like the
problem but i'm i'm very happy to say uh
i'm chris turner and you should listen
to hot breath
because the guests are of spectacular
quality
for example this british boy i said
british boy in a
using a french word beforehand i do
apologize all the other guests are
better than me
no way no this was great chris please
everyone
go subscribe to his youtube what where
can yeah where would you like people to
go support you check you out
um i i have yeah my youtube is
if you search chris turner comedy on
youtube i'll i'll come up
and i i put videos out every week
including my
my silly little podcast with my wife
called she doesn't read the news where
i tell her what's happened that week and
then do a rap about it um
and beyond that uh my
you know that's all i do i mean i yeah i
do shows and stuff
in the live world they're going to be
happening again soon and you can find
out about that
on my website but you know these are all
if there's all comedians listening
every comedian knows you don't want
comedians coming to your shows they just
sit at the back they don't laugh they go
yeah that was good oh oh smart yeah or i
could do better or
he needs to beef it up he should beef it
up a little bit don't you that was
that was a technique i used to use early
on i'd listen to comedian setups and i'd
try and guess the punchline
and if that wasn't their punchline i
would then use that as a joke
like i remember hearing an anthony
jezenite joke and i thought i knew what
the punchline would be
and it wasn't but i meant i just used
the setup he used and then put my
punchline on and it worked really well
um that was a fun thing to do and that
was always why it was good to watch
comedians because you'd be like ah
cool i just wrote a joke great very nice
it's not joke theft it's set up theft
only a few people could get away with
like an anthony jeselnik setup
i think you know yeah it's a very it's a
very specific style most people can't
pull off
audiences will always puzzle that i
switched to an american accent just for
one joke
[Laughter]
well i appreciate you uh beefing it up
with us here chris this was awesome man
so uh we'll be sure to go support you
however we can on your youtube
especially youtube is definitely uh
you're killing it on there so keep up
thank you for sure
well thank you for all the people who
were intrigued and i have to ask
questions and thank you for
asking your questions as well it was it
was thoroughly pleasant well thank you
chris well go rest up i know you have a
lot of gigs booked so uh we appreciate
you taking the time with us here at the
hot breath verse
and uh beef it up baby beef it up hot
breath verse
you